welcome to the presentation on solving
inequalities or i guess we call them
algebraic inequalities
so let's get started
if i were to tell you that uh well let's
just say x
is greater than 5
right so x could be
5.01
it could be 5.5 it could be a million it
just can't be 4 or 3 or 0 or negative 8.
and actually just just for convenience
let's actually draw that on the number
line
if that's the number line
and if this is 5
x can't be equal to 5 so we draw a big
circle here and then we would color in
all the values that x could be so x
could be just the smart could be 5.0001
it just it just has to be a little bit
bigger than 5 and any of those would
satisfy right
so let's just write some numbers that
satisfy 6 would satisfy it 10 would
satisfy 100 would satisfy it now if i
were to multiply or i guess divide both
sides of this
i guess we could say equation or this
inequality
by negative 1
i want to understand what happens
so
is what's the relation between negative
x
and negative five
and when i say what's the relation is it
greater than or is it less than negative
five
well six is a value that works for x so
negative six
is that greater than or less than
negative five
well negative six is less than negative
five right
so let me draw the number line here
if we have negative 5 here
let's just draw a circle around it
because we know it's not going to be
equal to negative 5
because we're just hiding between
greater than or less than so we're
saying 6 works for x so negative 6
is here right negative 6. so negative 6
is less than negative 5. so is negative
10 so is negative 100 so is negative a
million right so it turns out that
negative x is less than
negative 5.
and this is really all you have to
remember when you are working with
inequalities in algebra inequalities you
can treat them just the way uh a greater
than or less than sign you could treat
them exactly the way you would treat an
equal sign the only difference is is if
you multiply or divide both sides
of
the equation by a negative number you
swap it that's all you have to remember
let's do some problems and hopefully
that'll hit the point home and if you
ever forget you just have to try you
just remember this if x is greater than
5 well the negative x is less than
negative 5. and keep trying out numbers
that's what's going to give you the best
intuition
let's do some problems
so if i said that three
x
plus two
is let's say less than or equal to one
well this is pretty easy equation to
solve we just say three x
let's subtract two from both sides and
when you do add or subtract you don't do
anything to the inequality so if you
subtract 2 from both sides
you get 3x is less than or equal to
negative 1 right
and then
now we're going to divide both sides by
3. we get x is less than or equal to
negative 1 3.
right and notice we didn't change
anything because we divided both sides
by
a positive 3
right we could have actually done this
equation in a slightly different way
what if we subtracted 1 from both sides
so this is another way of solving it
what if we said 3x
plus 1 is less than or equal to 0 right
i just subtracted 1 from both sides and
now let's subtract 3x from both sides
and we get 1
is less than or equal to minus 3x right
i subtracted 3x from here so i have to
subtract 3x from here
now i would have to divide both sides by
a negative number
right because i'm going to divide both
sides by negative 3.
so i get negative 1 3 on this side
and based on what we had just learned
since we're dividing by a negative
number we want to swap the inequality
right it was less than equal now it's
going to be greater than or equal to
x
now did we get the same answer when we
did it both two different ways
here we got x is less than or equal to
negative one third and here we got
negative one-third is greater than or
equal to x well that's the same answer
right x is less than or equal to
negative one-third and that's i always
find that to be the cool thing about
algebra you can tackle the problem in a
bunch of different ways and you should
always get to the right answer as long
as you i guess do it right
let's do a couple more problems
let's erase this thing
there you go i'll do a slightly harder
one let's say negative
eight x plus seven
is
greater than
five x plus two
let's subtract five x from both sides
negative thirteen x plus seven is
greater than two
now we can subtract seven from both
sides negative thirteen
x
is greater than minus 5.
now we're going to divide both sides of
this equation by negative 13.
well very easy it's just
x
and on this side negative 5 divided by
negative 13 is 5 over 13 right the
negatives cancel out and since we
divided by a negative
we switch the sign
x is less than 5 over 13. and once again
just like the beginning if you don't
believe me try out some numbers and i
remember when i first learned this i
didn't believe the teacher so i did try
out numbers and that's how i got
confused that it actually works when you
multiply or divide both sides of this
equation by negative sign
you swap the inequality and remember
that's only when you multiply or divide
not when you add or subtract
i think
that should give you a good idea of how
to do these problems there's really not
much new here you do an inequality
or i guess you could call this an
inequality equation you do it exactly
the same way you would do a normal
linear equation the only difference
being is if you multiply or you divide
both sides of the equation by a negative
number
then you swap the inequality
i think you're ready now to
try some practice problems have fun